we're closing out 2019 what was your
favorite interview of the year some of
the performances and things like that
who's going first
I'm gonna go first Howard all right
Jason it's actually my favorite moment
of an interview from 2019 I you know
music is amazing and we have amazing
music performances but last year 2019 we
a country star Mary Morrison I love her
she's awesome and she's a solo artist
but she performs with Brandi Carlile
manda shires and Natalie MV in the
highway women and if she was here with
her band and impromptu she just did a
five-part harmony to her single that she
had all the time girl and it's freaking
beautiful yeah guy I remember turning to
her and saying you know when you guys
harmonize that's really good do you
think he could do it a cappella and they
broke right into it it was pretty cool
[Music]
let's try everything gonna be okay baby
girl don't you
[Music]
hello everyone's gonna be okay babe
yeah that was nice oh that was a special
moment you're right and none of that
[ __ ] was always 6:00 in the morning
I can't sing it just oh no that girl
dancing oh yeah and then there was
another cool acapella moment this is
here actually which is on the other side
of music but a def leppard they were
pretty they were pretty cool when they
did it though yeah they were great those
guys have no trouble performing you see
that's what I love about musicians they
can just break into a song and movie
right away
[Music]
what prompts me to always ask that
question is like I go let me here the
process of when you guys learn how to
harmonize like what does it sound like
without all the guitars and stuff that's
what really you know those are real
singers yeah that they can do all that
oh yeah studio tricks none of the
[ __ ] now you have to be listening to
each other and the Justine it's amazing
you know go ahead Oh
JD you're awfully chatty today what was
your big favorite the interview I like
Billy Eilish yeah she's a great
performer she came on with her brother
you a fan of Billy Eilish before not
really I didn't know much of our music
or anything and yeah her and her brother
Phineas came on they did great great
performances and it's you know usually
we learned something about the guests
it's very rare for the guests to learn
something about themselves and that's
sort of what happened when her parents
came in and I was raising Billy I asked
Billy's parents how she was conceived
the position Billy was conceived in for
the week and go home there's no question
there Billy and I've never yes please
[Applause]
Billy did you know that romantic you
know you come into the to the office and
all you know the doctor's office where
they're gonna do the you know and
there's all these women at the desks and
everything oh here's your bag here's the
room all right here's your dirty boat to
look good so you know so you know of
course this is the parade of guys every
day going into the room what's he doing
in the room yeah I mean it was really
something I remember made all the
newspapers to Sal you you're us Oh what
was one of your favorite interviews of
2/3 hands down your interview with the
great Dana Carvey oh he's a great guest
yes yeah and when he was on he sang Neil
Young songs as the church lady that was
great right that's how he said he became
the church lady he was doing a Neil
Young impression that's right and then
he was doing impressions of John and
Paul from the Beatles talking to each
other I love that so what's going on
down there poll big whoop to do with the
orange man to be going man I host the
orange man you know chumpy the president
I told her he's a big orange man he's
got little white circles around his eyes
and none that was Hillary's emails you
know they didn't know what to do what's
an email Paul and John talking that they
could talk now that was awesome
okay he went on for a long time with
that it was really good Ron what about
you so another one of your great
interviews I mean you pull [ __ ] out of
people's heads man it's just unreal
the [ __ ] that you pull out of people
when they get in here so Joe Namath was
in here and he talked about his
alcoholism and how he named his voice in
his head and tried to that try to make
him drink all the time that I thought
was really valuable advice that's a good
technique I went to Alcoholics Anonymous
right and this is where I learned about
that voice in my head that tells me to
this day once in a while just a glass of
red wine what do you call that voice
slick slick so you say do you talk to
your brain do you go and say oh
having a name for him and I didn't come
up with it
a man in alcohol hey one of the guys
that Joe that slick that's we got a name
for him my sponsor might have been the
guy that told me isn't that the greatest
technique when you think about it when
if you sit down and talk to your brain
calling a name whatever that child is in
you that wants that drink and you say
hey you're not gonna beat me today I'm
gonna kick your ass I know it works
there you go that was that was good yeah
it was wild yeah it was good a lot of
good moments in 2090 my Matt what do you
have Alec Baldwin love that out called
me too he's been in enough times that
when you guys sit and talk it kind of
sounds like just two guys having a
conversation at dinner and we're getting
to listen in on that yeah he makes it
easy he really does he always has
something to talk about that's
interesting and I could just sit and
listen to him all day last year he had a
story about being an anger management it
was pretty funny oh that was the best
you're gonna anger management you
realized you're not that angry right I
asked the guy to get chopsticks I want a
fork and put the chopsticks in the bag
so I get to my office I open it up in
this chopsticks in there so I go back
I'm like what the [ __ ] did I say to you
what is going nuts and you're like hey
dude calm down
absolutely hey man chopsticks could be a
lot of fun countless generations of
Asians have used [ __ ] American we shut
up there's all levels of anger well all
right Gary your last who was your
favorable I thought the interview of the
year maybe of the decade was Hillary
Clinton and one of the things I love
when you talk to people you don't ask
the obvious questions you were very
interested in her love story with Bill
and she talked about her first date with
Bill we went on about a a five-hour date
where we took a walk we get to the Yale
art museum and they have a Mark Rothko
exhibit and I said oh I didn't I I
missed that I wish I'd seen it because
the museum was closed because it was on
strike right so bill said why you really
like Rothko I said yeah I really I
really liked him I've never seen his
stuff in person but I've seen you know
you'll stay here to submit so he goes
off he comes back he introduces me to
this gentleman he goes this is you know
John the janitor and John the janitor
said he'll let us in if we pick up all
the trash on the lawn oh my god what an
operator pick up the trash yeah and then
we get to go in and see the Rothko's and
then we end up in the sculpture garden
this is a guy who is a born people
person and you know what he says which
is so important he says everybody has a
story and everybody deserves to have
their story told no kiss at this point
well we got there eventually not at the
museum not at the music I would have
kissed them at the museum no no not at
the museum well you know I was just
getting to know I don't know in those
days we did play a little hard to get I
thought that was a real insight
beautiful story well anyway we had some
great guests in 2019 we really truly did
and I thank them all they were all
fascinating